hey guys welcome back to another video
we're back on monster hunter world again
and we're gonna be talking about how to
get the temperate elder dragon tracks
and in specific how to get them the
fastest so let's get started so the
first method is to be doing the quest
called thunderous Rumble and the
Highlands which is unlocked after you
hit HR 49 and you fight a tempered Kirin
I'll be doing a guide for Ciaran soon if
we're having trouble so don't worry
about that but basically your objective
is to basically follow him around and
collect this footprints doing so will
give you a chance of getting tempered
elder dragon investigations the only
issue is that once you eliminate him
since it's an assignment once you beat
him you can't replay it anymore which
brings us to our next method which is
joining a quest or SOS flyers you can
either search for tempered Kirin quest
or temperate or other temper elder
dragon investigations like waha Zack
mashaallah T Ostra and naraka ghonte I
have solo guides for all these other
dragon monsters if you're having trouble
with defeating them by yourself so
definitely want to check that out if
you're having trouble it will be in the
I in the top right corner in the
description and at the end of the video
if you want to check those out once in
the question should obviously help the
guy fight the monster but pick up the
footprints and fur along the way to get
an investigation for yourself just cuz
you do an investigation or a quest
doesn't mean you're guaranteed an
investigation for yourself in the
background I faced a temper qu shala
with three other people and I only got
three footprints and no investigation
sometimes it happens so you're gonna
have to rinse and repeat until you get
one to speed up the process though equip
some gear that has scout fly range up or
scholar scout fly range up increases the
scout fly range that detects herbs
footprints and other things like that
and scholar which speeds up progress on
research levels and investigations the
hunters helm alpha and the surveyor term
will work perfectly since they contain
both skills eventually once you get an
investigation things get a little bit
more interesting I ended up getting a
tempered vol Haziq which seems to be the
most common out of all of them from what
I've heard from the community so the
first thing you want to do then is load
up the investigation of the way you've
received then proceed to track down the
monster once you see the monster in your
line of sight you want to put a ghillie
mantle on and follow them around I like
to follow them and learn the path that
they take while walking wrong because
it's usually in the same loop you can
use the ghillie mantle to hide from them
while gathering tracks while you're
walking behind them to follow their path
but at least for me ball hoseok did not
react to me even if I was two feet away
without the mantle I'm not sure how this
is with other monsters but that was the
case
for me once you find the route I'd like
to find a secluded place away from
danger wait about ten or so minutes the
monster will still walk and make
footprints
you basically relax watch a video read a
book for like ten minutes
follow their usual path pick up the
footprints and rinse and repeat
sometimes you'll find a lot sometimes
you won't find many it's just completely
RNG the other dragons you want to farm
for the most are Kirin and naraka ghonte
since they walk around a lot and produce
more footprints so definitely if you
don't have an investigation for those
keep trying to get more investigations
to hopefully get these two monsters that
you get tons more once you're satisfied
with the amount of investigations you
can leave the quest by simply clicking
return from quest you will still have
the investigations in your menu you got
from the footprints but your items will
not return and obviously you cannot
collect the rewards for beating it since
you didn't beat it do not click abandon
quest that will take you to the state
before you even accepted this
investigation and you will voice did all
that time for nothing in terms of
actually doing the quest and getting
these types of rewards you can do these
solar or with the group completely up to
you but I recommend doing investigations
with more rewards obviously when you go
and check an investigation you can see
how many rewards there are it's symbol
by a purple box the rewards you get for
beating these tempered elder dragons are
almost always if not all the time these
types of stones which will give you
decorations which you can then appraise
and in the menu this is basically going
to be the endgame of monster honor which
you can now do get augmentations on
weapons and getting better decorations
and that's it hopefully you guys did
enjoy that really quick guide and the
tempered elder dragon tracks these
tracks are a pain in the ass to farm so
that's why I wanted to do this video for
you all to hopefully speed up this
process a little bit faster and like I
said that's going to be the end of the
video if you guys didn't enjoy please
sure to give it a like really does help
me out subscribe for new I got a lot of
solo guides for Monster Hunter world in
terms of the monsters I got more coming
in the future got tutorials got guides
tons of stuff for monster and to keep
everybody up to date or if they need
help with a certain thing I'm gonna
start making guides on those as well
my two most recent videos are going to
be on screen if you guys do want to
check that out with that guys hope you
have a great rest of your day and peace
out